hey guys Joey here and today we have a
treat for you because we're going to be
scanning a bunch of our faces including
mine into NBA 2k 18 and NBA Live 18
alright let's go wait there's more I
have an extra eye in live just in case I
need to it is do the ball better
[Music]
[Music]
this one creeps me out because it looks
like my childhood pictures like I'm 5 or
something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right ready okay whoa well she's
gonna have cornrows when we go back
there this was so wrong there's
something a little strange about okay
let me at least take out my eyebrows
right I wasn't thinking you're like
eyeliner - for life yeah later on - Caze
I'm done
delete the you guys don't look like
Shrek okay let's get you started
start me up laughs no they're not oh it
looks like a gross baby ah ah you know
I'll take that down cleaning up the
courts
[Music]
oh I like what you did with your facial
hair that's confirmed you can build as
many monsters as you want an EA and they
come out pretty good
[Music]
so those were our face scans for both
NBA 2k 18 and NBA LIVE 18 now we did
have a couple of hiccups with the two
K's base scanning system but for the
most part they look pretty ok somewhere
a little grotesque but what do you guys
think just let me know in the comments
below and we will see you this time next
year for more face games see you later